barcel was a huge corporation then I
mean how long have you been working
there six years dude I've been this
September is going to be seven wow but I
mean I got hired Caleb hired me which is
fun which is fun to talk about now my
mom really drove me to the city that day
she saw how nervous I was I got the I
got the uh internship interview at 12 30
that day she drove me over there
and I was freaking out too because at
the time I was actually emailing with
what I thought was Erica nardini our CEO
it was really just our office manager
but they made it seem like it was a it
was whose office manager average office
manager his name was Brett he used to
work with us at Barstool yes sir so you
thought you were emailing with all with
the office manager from Barstool I
thought I was emailing with Erica as the
CEO but it was really Brett oh behind
that so I was I think I'm emailing Erica
I think it's like a business interview
type of thing as I'm going over there I
look at the Barstool Snapchat and I see
Caleb interviewing people so I'm saying
oh [__] this is kind of like a Content
thing and I'm [__] bricks because
now you're gonna be on camera and I'm
gonna be on camera I was a fan of Caleb
a fan of everybody it was a big Barstool
Femme and you're and you're nervous your
mother knows you're terrifyingly nervous
and also one thing that's value now this
is a value of having children that I
think are thicker you know is that you
can see when they're nervous easier
that's fair I get rosy cheeks I get big
time Rosy Cheeks I've been told that a
lot and I think that there's something
about that as a mother it must be
because you have all these other mothers
the kids on pills for nine months dude
they have no idea but he weighs 110 21
pounds yes sir so she knew I was worried
and then um
I know it's a continent to be there I
didn't realize did you ever go to our
old office by any chance I did one time
so do you remember how you get off the
elevator and everyone's sitting right
there
uh yeah it's so alarming quite
terrifying so I'm a Barstow fan no idea
what I'm walking into I get off the
elevator everybody's sitting right there
extremely scary I go walk by the bar
they say stand there for a second go
talk to Caleb I'm shooting bricks I'm a
Caleb Presley fan at the time still am
and um he asked me he just sits me down
and asks me are you fast and I said you
know what for my size I am pretty fast
when I play softball I get down the line
pretty quick people will be shocked I've
beaten out of ground ball or two in my
day he says prove it let's go downstairs
to the street to the 28th and when my
mom dropped me off I said Claudia
drive away don't stay here I don't know
what's gonna happen just don't know his
name Claudia yeah um I call her Claudia
sometimes it's a beautiful name yeah I
like Claudia my mom's thing so I like it
so I call her Claude sometimes she's
clawed in my phone but um so we go
outside she didn't move so I'm [__]
freaking out my mom is literally right
there and I'm out there with the camera
and Caleb I'm just telling myself right
she's right there if you watch the video
probably sitting in the car smoking a
cigarette but she's he was there that
checks out and I think that's awesome it
was great yeah I was just terrified if
she was gonna get out of the car and say
something or anything yeah we walked to
the corner run down the street Caleb
says you know what you are fish you're
hired we go up talk to Dave
as I'm walking out guys our our head of
social says what's your uh you have your
nicknames and I recently had watched um
Entourage and Goodfellas and Goodfellas
was a character named Sally balls
entourage is a character named Wally
balls I think just in my head I thought
Glenn evolves would be a name but I I me
and my friends really jokingly named
named me that like I would call myself
that jokingly we were talking about
gambling or something
yeah like you want to talk about horse
racing or anything yeah and um Sammy
spheres Ronnie rounds yes sir you know
what I'm talking about so I said uh oh
my friends call me granny balls then I
think that I think the name is it's a
it's a catchy name I think it's a good
name and then um yeah then pretty crazy
we me and Caleb started hanging out and
what about Mom at that moment to get
hooked because the craziest thing that
moms do is not leave and then Pretender
pretend they left dude you know what
happened actually so it was right it was
right when Barstool first moved to New
York from like so everybody living
across the country finally moved
together every Friday they were doing
Aloha Fridays
so um everyone would dress on Hawaiian
shirts and make margaritas and [__] I
was only I had just turned 20. it's nice
like Christmas almost yes sir I had just
turned 20. and they immediately say
you're the intern go get us alcohol and
of course had fake IDs oh yeah but I
don't want to use a fake ID and maybe
get in trouble he just started as a Long
Island person using fake IDs in the city
was always a bit of a scary thing
so I called my mom like hey how far away
are you you're on the bridge yet
she comes back bought me all the alcohol
and then bought underage children
alcohol now my co-workers that were of
age oh because I was just scared to buy
it for I was scared to get like in
trouble using a fake ID so my mom came
back drove back to the office went to
the liquor store down the street bought
us the alcohol and then I just gave it
to everybody else I was scared to not
deliver yeah and then I got Caleb
Chipotle and that was my first day at
work went to a Met game that night
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one